avant de tenter une médiation avant
tenté de réconcilation ce soir
j'aimerais vous écriviez chacune
il avait une petite pancarte sur une
pancarte le premier mot qui vous vient à
l'esprit quand on vous parle de l'autre
alors allez-y
si vous ne savez pas écrire vos mono des
données adn est ce que est ce que vous
avez fini le film super du mcri n'avait
pas de créer bas et bat allait venir
avec ses affaires au bac tu seras toute
seule ma belle as qu'on a une craie
kelly voulait pas lui prêter votre ba
voila par le volet calson la voix cassée
alors vous êtes mauvaises langues
allaient alors attention agathe ça y est
vous l'avez écrit premier mot qui vient
à l'esprit quand on vous dit kelly et
soyez franche d'accord si on va démarrer
temis avec ses beaux animaux ouais pas
ce petit on l'a kelly qu'est ce que vous
avez vu je vois pas lol ouais mais
pourquoi mais on sait que ces salles
parce que ça lui arrive d'être marrante
et vous agace
j'ai écrit mon meilleur ennemi c'est un
hôpital médian loge une fois elle m'a
dit qu'elle avait toujours rêvé d'avoir
une meilleur ennemi comme dans les
séries américaines et que l'été ravis
que je sois cette personne là bon bah
voilà
est ce que quelqu'un pourrait donner un
défaut et une qualité d'agathe je parle
du coup oui bah oui j'écris où je pars
vous parlez bien d'accord un défaut ni
une qualité
ouais
quand elle n'est pas là ça nous est
arrivé de nous parler à l'éprouvette
rigolote accord vraiment vous la trouvez
drôle à cet aspect-là je te déplacer et
et un défaut beaucoup trop lunatique
d'accord agathe qualité
kelly elle est
alors elle est
elle est marrante et indéfinissable elle
a beaucoup d'humour et un défaut tout à
l'heure en tout objet dansante à défaut
un défaut peut-être un peu et allez
allez allez
non c'est l'antre des fois malhonnête
ça commence cali est ce que vous avez
sur leurs questions à poser à gastes que
vous n'y avez jamais posée quand est-ce
que tu pars
est-ce que tu as une question à lui
poser et pareil pour magath alors
qu'elle est un tout vient à gastes si
vous avez la question avant agathe ce
que vous en avez eu allez-y l'une des
deux qui venait maria gatti allez-y
malaisie makeli
enfin en fait tu me détestes vraiment ah
oui bloquer non c'était la vérité
répondait sincèrement ok mais je pense
que je te déteste autant que tu me
détestes pour les filles sont terribles
on commence à mal ça commence à
ressembler à quelque chose
et pourtant rien n'était fait pour que
ces banques comme ça bah décalé pourquoi
un jour tu dis bonjour et le lendemain
tu parles pas mais parce que tu l'as dit
cyrus très lunatique
moi j'ai un problème en fait je suis
tellement c'est un côté très immature et
très entière c'est soit tout soit rien
et j'ai beaucoup de mal à cacher mes
émotions
oui mais je ne joue rien femmes et les
routes ont rien fait ça pose là je
promets que je vais être beaucoup plus
je vais beaucoup plus prendre sur moi
afin que cela ne se ressente plus sur
mon espace de travail en tout cas parce
que c'est vrai que c'est pas lieu alors
les chéris vous allez avoir trente
secondes chacune pour donner votre
version voilà à cette tension qui est
née entre vous dites vraiment toute la
vérité
si toute la vérité kelly et agathe
on va démarrer avec agathe alors mais en
vérité il ya unis andrew unique lacheny
trahison et c'est parce qu'à l'époque en
plus on se parle et on s'est dit des
choses assez personnelle et aucune des
deux n'a trahi l'autre jeudi renault
secret sont bien gardés enfin moi je
sais que j'ai confiance en kelly et
réciproquement là dessus mais en fait
c'est comme si vous seriez tous
demandent pourquoi vous détestez yann
barthès vous avez vu le match et pas
parce que je
même plus je suis bien des fois c'est
presque impalpable insondable alors papa
le pape a pu cette année c'est pareil je
n'aime pas parce que des fois je trouve
que c'est pâques elle rigole trop fort
ou que chez détour des trucs
complètement bête c'est pas votre style
de film que vous seriez pas là dans la
vraie vie c'est bien on n'a rien en
commun en fait mais il n'y a pas de
haine je dirais le provoque chez moi
aucun sentiment de haine ou de rage et
juste rien n'a en commun
d'accord mais vous aimeriez passer du
mode est plutôt rare et qu'elle vient de
dire non mais pas du tout du tout je
peux poser les questions à l'hyper v ner
le basic instinct seul vrai c'est vrai
ce serait basique et j'espère que ça va
se terminer pareil au pic à glace hockey
bas je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
elle pour une armée donné votre version
change comme si vous n'aviez pas entendu
celle d'agatha
ce qui a été à l'origine de cette
brouille embrouille the bruit moi je
suis arrivé à presles ouais donc je
pense qu elle c'était un petit peu
installé dans l'émission voilà avec les
autres chroniqueurs peut-être qu'elle
s'entendait bien avec tout le monde avec
vous enfin vraiment avec tout le monde
et peut-être comme voyant arriver elle
s'est dit bassett fume c'est plus moi la
jolie jeune de l'émission voilà ça veut
dire il peut y en avoir plusieurs pour
l'après trompe peut-être que ça a été
mal acceptée
et pourtant au début c'est vrai qu'on
sait on a parlé et bien sûr que l'on
garde clé de nos secrets ya aucun
vraiment écrire parce que je respecte je
la respecte quand même bien sûr et ouais
je pense que est ce que la relation avec
maxime gainey a joué pas du tout
franchement agacé parce que c'est un peu
leur chouchou
alors est-ce que vous avez des artisans
well as n'a aucun rapport avec vous tous
voilà oui bien mérité le chef leroy qui
paradent l'habitude mais rien à voir
donc voilà je vous dis vous êtes
complètement à côté là dessus
franchement kelly dit la vérité mais
c'est la vérité et il nous arrive même
de faire des rigolades kelly a gâté non
au contraire elles s'entendent très bien
contourner tous les trois il n'y a pas
de haine mais on doit parler d'une
histoire d'europe se fait pas du moins
ce qu'on va parler d'une histoire de
robe
un message bien pris un jeu moi je le
savais pas c'est quoi cette histoire qui
lie menace mais c'est une histoire de
filles c'est une histoire bête comme on
dit c'est un truc séries américaines
c'est que on a chacune nos vestiaires et
nos robes et un jour à gabala préféré
aller dans mon vestiaire choisir une
robe à moi ah ça c'est dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
nous verrons ça ça ne passe pas on
savait en fait vous détester mais vous
ne savez pas pourquoi entre fissa sais
pas est ce qu'une histoire de mec entre
vous mais vraiment bas z'êtes sûr mais
bien sûr ah non ne vous étiez pas sur
les mêmes dos pas là non non non je
n'étais pas du tout sur les mêmes bye
bye du tout est-ce que vous avez le même
style de mec tout l'été les deux je
pense phare fait je n'aurais
spécialement temps n'a pas un style en
particulier ouais d'accord c'est à dire
quoi peut-on publierai ici
non mais vraiment les chéris vous avez d
une enveloppe et vous allez nous dire si
vous avez décidé de repartir ensemble ou
séparément ah oui et un non dans l'
enveloppe vous allez enlever ou le oui
ou le non j'aimerais qu'on ne voit pas
ce que vous enlevez le fait mieux et on
va faire le dépouillement semble si vous
enlevez le nom villes des musiques in
sting si vous enlevez le nom il restera
donc le oui donc vous allez vous
réconcilier enfin si les deux ont dit
oui
s'il y en a une qui guette dit non et
l'autre dit oui c'est le sera non si les
deux disent non ce sera non non non
qu'est ce que c'est bon feeling ou est
ce que c'est bon je veux venir procéder
au dépouillement
alors est ce que vous avez dit qu'une
robe est ce que vous voulez vous
réconcilier et qu'on reparte sur de
bonnes bases l'année prochaine au gaz
qu'il y en a une qui ne veut peut-être
pas berçant bravo à bravo et cru à la
rva normes alors fait bon on a compris
je le fais je le fais je le fais non
mais non parfaite
au fait qu'est ce que vous avez fait au
départ c'est ce que vous avez fait au
départ je voulais vous lui donnez je
voulais pas mettre dans le bac je vais
vous le donnez donnez ce que vous voulez
donner mais je vous donne tout
et ces armes étaient dans l'europe si
vous avez choisi vous devrez vous en
donne quand même fort c'est ici non mais
ils aiment bien qu'on s'entende pas
c'est vrai nous paraît etc
bah oui parce que vois-je allons vous
parler vous engueuler pattes mais on
sait jamais entier mais ça ferait que ça
crée des tensions dans les loges jeudi
jean-michel bruit si cissé cheyrou
l'utilisent
on s'est retiré la situation désagréable
et endives oui mais ça c'est leur nom on
est mal à l'aise on est obligé de sortir
et tous les cherry pour tes libé novelli
cwi
vous voulez pourrait concilier avec
agathe pourquoi parce que ce serait très
ans restait un mystère
donc vous voulez vous concerne vous
seriez prête à être copine avec elle à
lui sortir avec el khachaba ce voile a
patiné que le quart d'heure d'accord
mais de se respecter nerf central
c'est-à-dire savez très bien
agathe on va voir si vous souhaitez vous
réconcilier avec kylie ou pas sia
jusqu'à la celle ci alors à gâteau pro
c'est non non on va voir oui oui oui
[Applaudissements]
les autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]